so I'm going to tell you today about a
way of looking at the world that I think
is substantially different from the way
that most people look at the world and
the way I want to tell you about looking
at the world today is I think more
inclusive than a standard sort of
materialist view of the standard
scientific view of the world of course
is that it's made up of familiar objects
and if the world is in essence a
material place but there's some very
potent limitations of that viewpoint
despite the fact that it's given us
tremendous power and the limitations are
essentially as follows the essential
materialist view can't tell us anything
about consciousness which is probably
the primary fact of experience
neuroscientists in recent years mostly
in the last decade of being trying to
crack the problem of consciousness and
they have absolutely made no progress
they've tried to associate consciousness
with neuronal activity but that seems to
be an incomplete answer because there's
many forms of neuronal activity in the
brain that aren't accompanied by
consciousness at all not only do
neuroscientists understand virtually
nothing about consciousness they can't
even really figure out what its function
is they can't understand why our brains
would go to so much effort to make us
aware of things when it isn't clear at
all that awareness is necessary for life
especially given that there are many
life forms on the planet that don't seem
to be aware at all the standard
materialist view is also insufficient
many other ways it's insufficient
philosophically I think as you probably
all know because a conception that
portrays the world is made up of objects
is in some really fundamental way dead
alright it doesn't seem to have a place
in it for human beings or replacing it
for meaning or a mode whereby you might
be able to conceptualize the real
existence of something like an emotion
or a dream or a motivation all phenomena
which are just as mysterious to
neuroscientists and to scientists in
general as consciousness now the problem
with this seems to be mostly
oriental if you have to ask people what
they know more than anything else they
know number one that they're conscious
they know number two that their internal
experience of life is composed of
emotions and motivational states which
although not rational and essential
structure are so real and relevant that
virtually everything that people do is
predicated on them so our current
viewpoint
despite its ability to give us
tremendous technological power seems to
eradicate from formal consideration many
many essential experiences that are
vital to life in fact even perhaps
primary nope
I'm going to suggest to you today that
there's an alternative viewpoint and I
think also it's one that although you
may be hearing about it formally for the
first time is also something that you
know unbelievably deeply how thousands
of years ago
Plato proposed that all knowledge was
remembering of course we don't believe
that today because we believe we gather
knowledge as a consequence of contact
with the world but you'll see today that
the knowledge that I'm going to share
with you will strike a deep chord of
remembering and it's because everything
that you've done throughout your life is
in one way or another predicated on what
I'm going to tell you today I'm going to
demonstrate this in a peculiar way I
think because I'm going to start by
telling you a story and the reason I'm
going to do that is because models of
the world that include phenomena like
consciousness and emotions and
motivations and actions and interactions
are generally portrayed formally in
stories and not in scientific theories
and it does turn out to be that stories
themselves have an identifiable
structure even a grammar that makes them
comprehensible furthermore it turns out
that even the simplest stories
especially if they're elegantly
constructed have an unbelievably
profound underlying meaning and you can
frequently see this most particularly in
children's stories so I remember I
showed my son when he was four years old
the Disney movie Pinocchio which on the
surface of it is a very strange tale
right it's a wooden puppet who wants to
become real so he has to rescue his
father
in the belly of a whale a structure that
could by no means be considered rational
that is in fact so surprising and
unexpected that it's remarkable to
imagine that grown men and women
including children can sit in a movie
theater and watch a story like that
unfold without ever thinking for a
second that it's absolutely peculiar
that they can be taken in by such a tale
and regard it experientially as real
Pinocchio is a deep deep story it has
echoes that go back three or four
thousand years to the earliest stories
that we know and it's so rich with
information that a child can watch it
over and over and over and over I think
my son wants Pinocchio thirty times why
well it's either because a child can't
tell the difference between fantasy and
reality or it's because there's
something to those stories that's much
more potent than we actually consciously
understand it's kind of interesting too
you know if you go to a sort of video
rental establishment you'll find that in
the top ten highest grossing movies of
all time are for Disney movies that are
animated fairy tales essentially
retelling of mythological stories they
strike a deep chord why all Shakespeare
was of course a great literary figure
said it perhaps better than anyone else
has which is not surprising because he
said many things better than anyone else
has he said all the world's a stage and
all the men and women merely players
they have their exits and their
entrances and one man in his time plays
many parts
and so following from that you can
imagine that a story is no more about
the props in the world than a play that
you go see is about the props on the
stage a drama is about the manner in
which people actually exist the emotions
that they feel the motivational states
they encounter the problems they have to
solve when they interact with each other
and the plays the thing from that
particular perspective in which we can
capture those aspects of our experience
that are not only real but essentially
human I'm going to tell you a little
story to begin this off with it's a kids
story written for children of about four
years of age but it's very very elegant
I tried to cut it down for this talk but
I found I couldn't because it was so
well edited that
every single piece of it had to fit in
to make the story complete and I'm going
to show you first the structure of the
story now this is a very useful diagram
in many ways it's very simple basically
it says this whenever you're doing
anything you inhabit a bounded world now
you know like for example you're sitting
here in this lecture there's things you
are paying attention to and things
you're not if I took most of you out of
this room right now and asked you
definitively what color the rug was you
wouldn't know or what color your chair
was for example or what the person next
to you was wearing and blessed that
person happens to be your husband or
your wife you wouldn't remember any of
those things and the reason for that is
when you're in a situation like this and
you're attending to a speaker most of
the occurrences that are unfolding
around you are irrelevant you don't
store them you only focus on certain
things well how do you decide what to
focus on given that there's virtually
unlimited number of things to pay
attention to well you have to conceive
of yourself as being somewhere always
and you have to conceive of yourself as
going somewhere so you could say in in a
real sense the world you inhabit is a
journey it's a journey from point A to
point B a journey from what is to what
should be a journey from the place you
are which is insufficient in some
important manner to a place that in some
important matter is going to be better a
standard story has exactly that
structure child comes home and you say
well what happened to you today on the
way to school setting up the little
narrative structure in the childhood
unfold the sequence of events that he
encountered if the story's more
interesting than just a recount of
exactly what happened to it usually
involves the encounter with something
unexpected on the way to point B and a
description of the manner in which that
encounter with the unexpected was
resolved typical story now why would you
want to know that why would you want to
listen to it well it's because on your
journey from point A to point B all
sorts of unexpected things always happen
and if someone else has encountered
something unexpected and conjured up a
decent solution to it it could well be
worth your time to listen well maybe
there's a pattern to encountering
unexpected things maybe there's a
proper way to encounter the unexpected
maybe it's the case that in our
collective wisdom as human beings we've
gathered up representations of ways to
encounter the unexpected that we put
forth in our stories how should you face
what you don't understand well now I'm
going to tell you this story it's
written for four-year-old kids but I
want you to take a look at it for a
moment from a different perspective and
see if you can imagine exactly what it
is that it's say there's no such thing
as a dragon well we all know that right
a dragon is a fictitious creature
reptilian terrible lives forever
breathes fire hoards gold strange
combination of attributes why would
something terrible and ancient
hold a treasure Billie Bixby was rather
surprised when he woke up one morning
and found a dragon in his room it was a
small dragon about the size of a kitten
the dragon wagged its tail happily when
Billy patted its head it's interesting
you know in Chinese mythology dragon is
a positive figure in European mythology
the dragon is something to face in
combat and destroy or something to face
in combat and build something out of the
pieces left over from the dragon Billy
went downstairs to tell his mother it's
no such thing as a dragon said Billy's
mother and she said it like she meant it
remember once my daughter had a
nightmare she's about four this was at
the time when she first started to
notice graffiti and litter and both
graffiti and Leonard bothered her she
couldn't understand the motivations
behind the graffiti artist and she
didn't like the fact that there was
litter cluttering up the world's order
and the reason she got sensitive to that
as a child was because children are
really really dependent on order right I
mean and the reason for that is that
their realm of competence is rather
restricted so they'd like to see things
Mac messed up so little kids for example
they're not happy with you if you play a
game with them and then mess around with
the rules of the game they don't like
that at all they think that that's
immoral activity to shake up the
structure of the game well anyways well
she was pondering all this she came into
our bedroom one night and said dad I had
a nightmare now we all know right
nightmares aren't real just like dragons
dreams aren't real of course which
raises the question of why in the world
you'd bother having them six or seven
hours a night every single day of your
life and why they're a recognized
feature of animal behavior all the way
down to the amphibian level she said I
dreamt that there was a clear flowing
stream but in the stream there was all
sorts of garbage and it scared me and
bothered me so much I woke up so I told
her look close your eyes and imagine the
stream it's full of garbage what should
you do about it she said well I should
take the garbage out of the stream I
said alright so picture the stream
picture yourself cleaning the garbage
out of it she calmed down and went back
to sleep why well because dreams
concentrate on threat we know that they
present threats to you threats you
haven't been able to deal with well
there's a part of your brain that tracks
threats and it's not really all that
smart in some ways all it does is say
look here's a problem and it's waiting
for the rest of your brain to conjure up
some solution that problem and if it
doesn't conjure up a solution then it
just presents the problem over and over
and over and over and over so people who
have post-traumatic stress disorder for
example who've been really upset by
their contact with something unexpected
dream about the same tragedy forever
until they solve it and they solve it by
facing it and living it over and over
voluntarily so you might think right off
the bat from listening to that little
story that suggesting to your
four-year-old daughter who's just had a
nightmare that her fears aren't real and
that the dream representation of them
isn't real because it's not tangible
like a table might not really be the
best approach to the problem
so you see Billy he's pretty much got it
right right off the bat right
the dragon wagged his tail happily when
Billy patted its head Billy went
downstairs to tell his mother there's no
such thing as a dragon said Billy's
mother and she said it like she meant it
so there's a dragon in this house now
the next thing he might wonder is how
often have you actually gone into a
house where there's a dragon my guess is
if you don't take this particularly
specifically and allow yourself to use
your imagination and to think
metaphorically for a moment you've all
encountered dozens of houses that were
filled right to the rafters with various
dragons all of which were being
studiously ignored by the people who
inhabited the house Billy went back to
his room and began to dress the dragon
came close to Billy in a friendly manner
and wagged its tail but Billy didn't Pat
it if there's no such thing as something
it's silly to Pat it on the head
Billy washed his face and hands and went
down to breakfast the dragon went along
it was bigger now almost the size of a
dog Billy sat down at the table
the dragon sat down on the table this
sort of thing was not usually permitted
but there wasn't much Billy's mother
could do about it she'd already said
there was no such thing as a dragon and
if there's no such thing you can't tell
it to get down off the table sometimes I
sit with friends of mine who have very
young children to eat say and the
children two or three years old don't
sit at the table they sit on the table
or they run around the table or they run
around the table and pull things off the
table or they run around the house and
pull things off all the shelves in the
house and keep their parents so busy
chasing them around that they have no
time whatsoever to interact as adults
well you have to wonder under those
circumstances whether you're dealing
with a child or a dragon so to speak and
you also might wonder whether or not the
dragon is large and unruly precisely
because the parents are completely
unwilling to admit that it actually
exists
mother made some pancakes for Billy but
the dragon ate them all mother made some
more but the dragon ate those too mother
kept making pancakes until she ran out
of batter Billy only got one of them but
he said that's all he really wanted
anyway one time an acquaintance of ours
in Boston brought their son over to be
babysat at our house and his nanny had
just been in a car accident so he was
being shunted from house to house while
his parents went off to work and he
didn't have very good reputation this
kid he's about 4 and he came over to our
house and with his mother in the morning
and she dropped him off and she said
well he probably won't eat all day but
that's all right
and I thought no he's 4 if he doesn't
eat all day ah that's not alright right
because kids if they don't eat they're
basically horrible right they don't
sleep but they don't eat they're
horrible so it isn't alright that he
doesn't eat so then you think well maybe
there's some sort of dragon associated
with this child that happens to be
interfering perhaps with his ability to
eat so I came back at noon my wife had
taken care of the children that day and
I walked in the house and the other four
or five kids that we had in the house
were off playing and this little kid was
standing in the corner like really
isolated and looking you know upset
fundamentally so I went over and I poked
him a bunch because generally if you
poke a kid a little bit you know
well they'll go like this you know they
sort of back off but sooner or later you
can crack them and they'll smile and
then they'll play not this kid boy
there's no bloody way he's going to play
with me and that was act like he'd
already learned that adults should
either be ignored or that they were
trouble and he wasn't going to let any
adult into his little world so there was
absolutely a dragon associated with that
little boy and it was eating all his
pancakes Billy went upstairs to brush
his teeth mothers started clearing the
table the dragon who was quite as big as
mother by this time made himself
comfortable in the hall rug and went to
sleep
I really like this one by the time Billy
came back downstairs the dragon had
grown so much he filled the hall Billy
had to go around by way of the living
room to get to where his mother was I
didn't know dragons grew so fast said
Billy there's no such thing as a dragon
said mother firmly cleaning the
downstairs took mother all morning
what with the dragon in the way and
having to climb in and out of windows to
get from room to room so you know you
think back in your own experience when
you've gone to a house where there's a
dragon hiding underneath the living room
rug and nobody's saying anything about
it and then you think how long does it
take to get something absolutely simple
done in a house that's absolutely jammed
to the rafters with unfinished business
forever right organizing people in a
household like that to even do something
as simple as go out for breakfast in the
morning or even perhaps to make a meal
is virtually impossible why well because
there's something going on in the
household that has been studiously
ignored for a very long time
and has grown so large as a consequence
that it occupies the whole domain by
noon the dragon filled the house its
head hung out the front door its tail
hung out the back door and there wasn't
a room in the house that didn't have
some part of the dragon in it
when the dragon awoke from his nap he
was hungry the bakery truck went by the
smell of fresh bread was more than the
Dragon could resist he ran down the
street after the bakery truck the house
went along of course like the shell on a
snail the mailman was just coming up the
path with some mail for the Bixby's when
their house rushed past him and headed
down the street he chased the Bixby's
house for a few blocks but he but he
couldn't catch it when mr. bixby came
home for lunch
the first thing he noticed was that his
house was gone luckily one of the
neighbors was able to tell them which
way it went you know that sort of thing
happens to people not infrequently -
right hey they're not really looking
around much at what's going on and they
come home from work one day and their
house is gone and what does that mean
well maybe their children have become
completely alienated from them or maybe
their wife has decided suddenly but of
course not so suddenly to leave why well
according to this story it's because
something ignored was growing in the
house mr. bixby got in his car and went
looking for the house he studied all the
houses as he drove along finally he saw
one that looked familiar
Millie and mrs. Bixby were waving from
an upstairs window you know in the 1890s
in India when a house was being built
the local priest equivalent to the
priest would come by to set the
foundation stone and when he set the
foundation stone he'd take a big spike
and drove it into the ground and the
reason he drove it into the ground at
the place where the foundation was going
to be laid was to keep the great dragon
that is underneath the earth firmly
pinned down by its head so it couldn't
move and shake the house to bits what
does that mean well it means the same
thing that's meant in the New Testament
when you're told not to build your house
on a foundation
of sound right doesn't matter how good
the house is or how well-constructed it
is or how rich it is if the foundation
is made out of sand or if it rests on
top of the dragon there's nothing in
that household that's ever going to be
accomplished that's positive and the
wealth the display that the house might
consist of is nothing but a sham mr.
bixby climbed over the dragon's head
onto the porch roof and through the
upstairs window how did this happen
mr. bixby asked it was the dragon said
Billy there's no such thing mother
started to say there is a dragon Billy
insisted a very big dragon and Billy
patted the dragon on the head the dragon
wagged its tail happily then even faster
than it had grown the dragon started
getting smaller
soon it was kitten sized again how do
wine dragons this size said mother
why did it have to grow so big I'm not
sure said Billy but I think it just
wanted to be noticed so the first thing
you might think about is just what
happens if you don't pay a bill like
really don't pay it right I mean when it
first comes in it's only the size of a
kitten but if you leave it alone for two
or three years it pretty much grows into
a full-fledged dragon why well because
things that you ignore have a life of
their own complex life like a bill bills
attached to a whole industrial complex
right one of whose major functions is to
make sure that you pay the bill and if
you don't pay the bill then you
immediately find out what it's connected
to
it's connected to something immense and
very troublesome and if you allow the
full force of that thing to manifest
itself it's not pretty so one lesson
from this story is that if something's
nagging at you just a bit it's probably
better to deal with it before it turns
into a full-fledged dragon and then you
might think well what if it's already a
full-fledged dragon right I mean then
what's your options there's nothing left
but to run away and so then I can tell
you what we know from fifty years of
studying the outcome of clinical
psychological interventions so let's
take an extreme case right let's say
something truly terrible has happened to
you and as a consequence of that you're
in shock
post traumatic shock which is a
condition that's sufficiently serious to
damage your brain over time it's not
only a psychological disorder it's a
physical disorder if you really stress
your cortisol levels shoot up and if
your cortisol level shoot up that
cortisol and high doses is a neurotoxin
starts to damage your brain so let's
take a very extreme case and imagine
that you've been violently sexually
assaulted and as a consequence of that
you're in post-traumatic shock how do
you get cured so that means you can't
really go outside you certainly can't
encounter anything that's associated
with the event your sense of integrity
and personal safety has been completely
destroyed is there any way you can get
back on your feet and all there's a
woman named
phowa in New York I think one of the
world's top clinical psychologists and
she's been dealing with women who have
post-traumatic stress disorder for
decades and she's found a treatment that
works and the treatment is this she has
the women relived the event in as much
detail as possible over and over in
their imagination with the accompanying
emotion and she's found because she's
done physiological measurements on her
clients that those women that allow
themselves to get the most fully upset
as a consequence of the reliving get
better faster and stay better longer the
clinical evidence is absolutely clear
when you take someone to therapy you're
basically doing two things to them well
3 you allow them to confess what's wrong
with them because it's really useful to
actually say what it is that's bothering
you makes it clear and distinct you help
the person get their story straight
because you have to have your story
straight right you have to know where
you're coming from and you have to know
where you're going because otherwise
there's no structure for your life then
the third thing is if your path from
point A to B is being blocked by
something that you're afraid of you
better learn to confront it because if
you don't it will grow and expand until
it turns into the kind of dragon that
occupies your whole house
this is another representation of the
story that's a simple story I think it's
one that's really most applicable to
children that there are aspects of it
that are most applicable to children
sexual desire one obviously isn't it's a
map of motivation it basically says this
and it's easy to understand if you think
go to a movie doesn't matter what
country it's made there's certain things
that always happen right like two broad
classes of fiction adventure and romance
what's an adventure to go to new lands
and discover something new and become
transformed as a consequence what's a
romance to meet another person who's
certainly as complicated as anything you
could meet on an adventure and again to
be transformed as a consequence of the
contact to fundamental plots why why are
their fundamental plots and why can we
understand them without them being
explained to us what's because
fundamentally we're all very very
similar we have a finite set of basic
needs so for example hot people would
rather be cool thirsty people would
rather have water hungry people would
rather eat and these motivations color
what we conceive of as our ultimate
destiny so in the Old Testament for
example an agrarian community often
hungry paradise was construed as the
land of milk and honey well why well
milk is high in fat and honey is high in
glucose and if you're hungry really
hungry there's nothing you want more
than fat and sugar affiliative desire we
like to be around other people sexual
desire a fundamental sub element of a
romantic plot these underlying
motivational systems of ours set us up
bounded worlds within which we live so
for example if you fall in love with
someone and you construe your destiny as
being with them any indication that
they're pleased with you is going to
produce a rush of positive emotion why
because our emotional systems are set up
so that any sign that we're moving
towards our goal is responded to with a
rush of positive emotion and conversely
a frown from the person that you love
especially in the initial ages of our
initial stages of a romance is
at with a flood of negative effect why
because anything that stops us on the
path that we've chosen produces negative
emotion that's how we're set up and our
emotional systems are actually quite
straight forward we pause it a goal the
thing about people is that we can pause
it virtually anything as a goal that's
one of the things that distinguishes us
from animals so we can all be thrilled
to death when our favorite soccer team
scores a goal because we participate in
what they're doing the same way we
participate in watching a protagonist on
a movie or in a book we can feel it we
embody it we even know now that the
neural systems that I utilize to watch a
movie involve the same neural systems
that the actor is utilizing acting out
the part so when you say you understand
someone else
what you mean is your body is set to do
exactly the same thing their body is and
your emotional systems are locked on
exactly the same way there's our so when
they experience something and you're
watching it you experience an echo of it
and that's what understanding means and
it turns out as well that those neural
systems that allow us to embody someone
else and to imitate them are right
underneath the structures that we've
evolved to use for language and what
that indicates is that mostly what we
use language for is to tell stories to
tell stories about the way that people
act so that we can derive information
not about what the world's made of
because we don't really care about that
some fundamental way but instead how
should we act that's the fundamental
question how should we act now if you go
see a movie about a thug the message
there is given that the thug generally
comes to not-so-good end don't act like
a thug right interesting though it might
be compelling as a lifestyle at least
sufficiently compelling so you'll watch
it it's not a good long-term strategy
what is a good long-term strategy you
know we've been collecting stories as
people for we don't know how long really
we don't know 100,000 years maybe
there's been creatures like us
indistinguishable from us for a hundred
thousand years and we know that
societies that appear to be more or less
as archaic as those old societies tell
us
stories have rituals have mythology we
have ancient written stories at the ANU
mulisch which is a sumerian story the
oldest written story we have 4000 years
old based on a oral tradition that's
probably 20,000 years older than that
we've been collecting stories for a long
long time what do they mean what are
they good for well imagine this you know
you tell a story to your husband or your
wife hey but something interesting that
you saw right well then imagine that you
could collect a thousand of the most
interesting stories and then imagine
that you were some kind of literary
genius like like Shakespeare and you
could take those thousand interesting
stories and boil them down to a hundred
really interesting stories and then
imagine that you had ten thousand years
to gather up those hundred most
interesting stories and average them and
you could come out with one perfect
story the best story the most
interesting story that you could
possibly tell well that's what a myth is
it's the most interesting story you can
possibly tell and just as this little
story that I just told you how to
underlying mythological structure
virtually every story you'll ever see
has such a structure that's why it's
compelling to you and when you meet
someone who's charismatic or who holds
your attention or who you're interested
in the probability that they're acting
out a mythological fragment is very very
high and that's why it is that your
attention is captivated by them what's
the world like from this perspective
well look you know you're all sitting in
this room you think if I took you out of
here how would you describe it well
you'd say it was full of chairs there
was a table lights well why would you
pick that level of resolution any like
why wouldn't you say well you know the
average ceiling tile had about 15,000
dots on it doesn't seem like a relevant
data point right you say the same thing
about the rug there's no nothing
stopping you from counting the number of
stains or the number of red spots or the
way the light plays off your partner's
shirt or the shine on your shoes and if
you are an artist say I'm trying to make
a representation of this room you'd
concentrate on aspects of it we're
completely different from those that
you're concentrating on now you talk
about chairs TV cameras cabinets tables
they're functional they're objects right
they're tools they're tools they're
things you can use normally when you're
going from point A to point B you divide
up the world into things you can use
those are things you see your perceptual
systems do this things you can use and
things that might get in the way and as
you move from motivated world to
motivated world the little stories that
you inhabit you chop the world up in
different pieces so a piano for a
concert pianist is different as a
different phenomena than a piano for
someone who has no musical education
but you're always parsing up the world
in terms of what it's good for how it
can serve your purposes and you even see
it that way now the question is the
complicated question isn't so much how
do you parse up the world into things
that are useful to you like chairs the
complicated question is what do you do
when something that you don't expect
happens so imagine you've had a 15 year
long marriage and you find lipstick on
your husband's collar not once but three
times and then you think well I thought
I had a map right I thought we were both
in the same game I thought we were both
going from point A to the same point B I
thought we had established a shared
structure of interpretation but I find
that there's some aspect of his apparent
behavior it's completely outside my
scope of interpretation what do you do
well you can choose to ignore that right
it's easy to do that why would you not
why would you ignore it because if you
don't ignore it you have to think he's
not who I thought he was and that's
really not a good thing to think because
people are really really really
complicated and if they're not who you
think they are you have no idea who they
might be and you also might think well
maybe I'm not who I think I am because
after all I got sucked into this
situation I thought I'd pretty much
understood the world and turns out that
I certainly don't understand the office'
gender and there's some indication that
I really don't even understand myself
because fundamentally I'm so clueless
and then you might think well when did
this start this cluelessness how long
have I been blind well do you really
want to
that question well not generally right
it's easy to keep the dragon in the
closet which is where it tends to live
what happens when you encounter
something you don't expect for a long
time psychologists thought that people
learned fear right so your typical
person your typical lab rat was a calm
and creature now it's a funny thing and
because if you take a lab rat out of his
home cage and he put him in a new cage
where you want to teach him say to be
afraid of something to be afraid of a
light paired with a shock which is a
typical psychological experiment the
funny thing about the rat is you've got
to let him calm down before he's normal
well except that you might think that
the not comrade is also the normal route
right you take the route out of this
cage and you put him in the new cage and
what does he do he goes like this why
well he's a rat right someone might eat
him so he's a bit nervous about being in
this new situation rats do not like
being in new situations they don't like
bright light if you put them in a new
situation that's brightly lit they go
right over to the corner because they
think maybe cats won't find them rats
are so afraid of cats that they never
even have to meet a cat to be afraid of
them so you can take a rat that's never
seen a cat in his life and if you let
him smell some cat odor or show him a
cat he'll well I'll tell you if you show
a rat a cat somewhere he doesn't expect
it he will run back to his burrow and
scream for 24 hours now you imagine how
scared you'd have to be to scream for 24
hours especially given rattle he lives
about a year so that would be for you
like screaming I'll be like screaming
for 3 months right so the rat runs back
to his burrow and he screams at every
other rat who hears him scream freezes
and they all stay like that for 24 hours
until they sort of calm down and then
the first thing they do is they go back
to the place where they saw the cat and
they start to map it out so they do
these things called corner runs which is
so the rat wants to go back to this
territory knows the territory might be a
place where he gets food is the cat
still there well you might think stay in
the
Burrell right but then maybe you don't
get something to eat so the rad goes
back to the place where the cat was
carefully and then he hunches down and
he runs over part of it and if nothing
kills him then he goes back and does the
same thing with a little more of the
territory until finally the rats have
run all over the territory again then
they go back to eating making love
paying attention to their families
because mats are quite social despite
the fact that they're rats
the rats smart enough to go back to the
scene of the crime so to speak right
it's not going to let the dragon that
might be there grow the rat knows that
if something is terrifying it should be
investigated not run away from the
question is what do you encounter when
you encounter something you don't expect
and so you say well you've got your
spouse mapped out right but then they do
something you don't expect which
hopefully happens fairly regularly right
because otherwise you get bored with
them they do something you don't expect
you think aha who is that person
precisely and what that means is that
what what that means is that when you
encounter something unexpected you
actually can't see what's there why
because it's too complicated you might
have to spend a month talking to your
spouse to figure out just exactly why
they have that particular peculiar
opinion you have to explore and dig to
find out how they map the world if you
encounter something unexpected the first
thing you see is not the world the first
thing you see is just a sense of
discomfort and fear combined with some
latent curiosity that the world is not
the way you thought it was now how do
you find out what the world is actually
like we have to investigate it you have
to investigate it means you have to take
a risk you have to move forward the same
way that people do in psychotherapy you
have to find the thing that you're
bordering on avoiding and go in and map
it now it's a curious thing you know
common anxiety disorders Agra phobia
Agra phobia is a generalized anxiety
disorder and people who suffer severely
from Agra foam you often get to the
point where because of their panics
their housebound they can't go outside
their room or their house now they'd run
away from the room or their house too if
they could but
there's nowhere to run so they're pretty
much stuck being somewhere so an agra
fort comes in for therapy I think well
what do you do with them and you say
well then Agra for big says I can't go
on elevators and you say okay well let's
go try and you say alright well relax
let's teach the person to breathe which
really doesn't help that much but it
makes them feel better you can do this
without teaching them to relax it
doesn't matter a bit but it does help
them feel better say okay well there's
the elevator how close can you get to
the elevator say well I you know I can't
really get more than like 220 feet
that's Maxim I said okay let's go up to
20 feet there and let me do that and
then you let them stand there and stand
there and stand there and stand there
and stand there soonerlater they get
bored of being 20 feet from the elevator
and then you say well look you know
let's could you go 10 feet that no I
couldn't go 10 feet that's too close how
about could you go three more feet yeah
I think I could do that so they go three
more feet and you let them stand there
and they find out nothing terrible is
happening sooner or later and then they
go another three feet and then they go
another three feet and then they're
they're like confronting the elevator
and then they're inside the elevator but
they're going like this so they don't
want to look at the elevator right so
you say well you got a look at the
elevator you look at the numbers you can
look at the buttons so they do that then
you think well could we go up a floor no
we couldn't go up a floor okay well I'll
tell you what we'll just close the door
I'll put my hand and it'll open again
could you do that yeah I could do that
step by step sooner or later and usually
sooner bang they've gone up a floor
right so then what happens they go home
and have a fight with your husband
that's been brewing for like 15 years
why well it's not because the elevators
symbolically related to the fight has
nothing to do with it it's because what
the person learns in the combat with the
unknown which just happens to be taking
the guise of an elevator is that they
can confront things that frighten them
without being destroyed by the
confrontation and so what you see
immediately and this was contrary to an
original psychoanalytic prediction is
that man you know you take that person
out you teach them they can go on the
elevator and right off the bat they're
going to shopping malls there
in taxis there back in the subway and
they're standing up for themselves at
home generalization why because they
didn't learn that the elevator wasn't
frightening that isn't what they learned
they learned that despite the fact that
the elevator was as terrifying as
anything they've ever encountered they
were actually up to the challenge and
now that's a really useful thing to
teach someone right because if you have
an obsessive-compulsive patient I had
one who actually used to work with
radiation now he was Terra he worked in
a some kind of bio lab in Montreal
people with obsessive-compulsive
disorder often very frightened if
they'll contaminate someone else so like
typical obsessive compulsive obsession
would be all go to a shopping market
I'll touch some fruit from you know some
third-world country I'll get some nasty
bacterial disease I'll bring it home and
I'll give it to my kids well you tell
them look you know the chances of that
are like 150,000 when they look at you
only think I don't care if the chances
are only 150,000 what if my kids die and
you think well yeah that does pose a
problem doesn't it because it isn't
exactly clear from a logical perspective
where you should draw the risk line with
the obsessive-compulsive you do exactly
the same thing you say look yeah your
fear is real don't kidding because
lurking at the bottom of their fear is
the same fear that everybody else has
right same fear I might die I might get
sick I might lose the people that I love
not only might that happen it's going to
happen why aren't people afraid of that
all the time we don't really know
obsessive person becomes aware of it
what do you tell them you say do it
anyway do it anyways and they learn
quickly that if they don't run away from
the thing they're afraid of there's
something in them that responds to it
they learn that the fear is not larger
than they are now I like Aetna foa's
case in particular because you always
might wonder with this like what's the
limit right okay yeah that sounds good
theory but what if something really
terrible is happening to you well what's
happened dead new foa's patients that's
up there and with terrible right to be
nuts up there with terrible right
stripped of social dignity violated
physically that combines two of people
most specific fears well then there's
other kinds of confrontation to it I
like the story of Solzhenitsyn I think
it's really a good one because there's
different kinds of dragons right there's
natural dragons like death and disease
and then there's social dragons like
bureaucracies and tyrannies Alexander
Solzhenitsyn you may or may not know was
a prisoner in the Soviet gulag
concentration camp system that by his
report at least killed 60 million people
between 1919 and 1959 right 60 million
that's ten times as many as Hitler
killed at least with regards to the
genocide 60 million people
Solzhenitsyn he had a pretty nasty life
I mean first of all he's on the Russian
front which was a nasty place to be
Mamie was captured by the German so they
didn't like Russians so they put them in
separate prisoners of war camp partly
because Stalin who is a consummate
paranoid wouldn't sign the Geneva
Convention on the treatment of prisoners
of war so the Germans set up extra Theo
W camps for the Russians and they starve
generally so badly that if other PLW
were in the vicinity they'd throw food
packages over the wire even though they
themselves weren't particularly well fed
so then so the war ends the Russians win
it so Shinkansen goes back to Russia
right and what happens he's thinking you
know wow this is over we help defend the
fatherland we're going to get if not a
hero's welcome at least some welcome but
Stellan figured no no these Russians had
been to the West they were contaminated
by their exposure to the Western
economic system and as a consequence of
that they posed a threat to the
integrity of the Soviet state so he just
threw them all in concentration camps so
fine so Solzhenitsyn sitting there in
this concentration camp on a coal pile a
coal pile which contained this kind of
clay that his compatriots would eat
because they were so damn hungry that it
was better to have the clay in their
stomach than nothing at all and he
thought all right what the hell did I do
to get here
which is really a remarkable thing to
think right because like there was the
Second World War and that probably
couldn't be pinned directly on him and
then there is Stalin who was you know
really one of the world's worst monsters
and then there's the concentration camp
and the POWs camp and like a lot of
things happen to Solzhenitsyn but
he said he had nothing but time to think
in this concentration camp and he wasn't
really that happy with the way things
turned out so he made a vow in the camp
and the vow was this he said he is going
to go back over his whole life whole
life right from day one and try to
remember every time he ever did
something he thought was wrong he
thought right not someone else but that
that gave his conscience a pang and he
said well since I don't have anything
better to do I mean spend like the next
10 years seeing if I can undo all those
little knots in my soul that I tied and
the consequence of that was that he
wrote a book called the Gulag
Archipelago
write three volume book 19 hundred pages
long he memorized it because there
wasn't any paper-and-pencil available
for him in prison and then it circulated
in the underground in the Soviet Union
for years before it got published in the
West published in 1975 definitely one of
the literary events that brought down
the Soviet Union I think that's kind of
interesting isn't it think this one guy
right it's got numbers tattooed on his
arm he's as skinny as a rail he's 3/4
dead he's been beat to death in 15
different ways he decides under
completely unreasonable circumstances
that he's going to take personal
responsibility for the position that he
happens to find himself in the
consequence of that 25 years later is
that Solzhenitsyn still around
Soviet Union isn't and you think well
that can't be the way the world works
now can it but then you think this to
like do we really know how the world
works right we've had a pretty nasty
century in the last hundred years right
we had the Nazis we had mild side tongue
we had the recent tragedies in Africa we
don't seem to learn anything about
genocide someone like Solzhenitsyn says
well you know might be your fault Why
What are you ignoring good question can
you make peace with your own family it's
not so easy right it's probably no
easier than making peace between the
Israelis and the Palestinians what do we
encounter when we encounter something we
don't understand
we all know it's not the simple world of
objects the simpler world of objects is
something we've learned to see the real
world is way more complicated than
what we just see let me give you an
example when I was in Montreal in 1985
my computer crashed so what do you do
when your computer crashes well we're
not when the computer encounters
something unexpected it crashes it can't
do a damn thing about it you have to fix
it so I checked the monitor it was okay
I wouldn't go on seemed alright and I
noticed my lamps weren't working so I
went the fuse box so all the fuses
seemed okay so then I went outside to go
down to the corner store to get a
cigarette and I saw that outside all the
lights were off the traffic lights were
off right the whole city was in darkness
then I found out the next day that there
was a solar wind big solar flare put out
a big cloud of electrons zipped along to
earth at the speed of light put an
electrical pulse through the
hydroelectric grid and Quebec crashed my
computer well I hadn't thought until
that point that the integrity of my
computer was dependent on the stability
of the Sun everything is way more
complicated than it looks and when you
just look at something you see a very
simple representation of what's actually
there what do you encounter when you
encounter something unexpected well when
you first encounter it you don't know
all you know is that frightens you but
it makes you curious think dragons right
every primates afraid of lizards keeping
us chimpanzees don't like snakes if you
take a chip it's never seen a snake you
throw it show it a snake it will hit the
roof of its cage then it will look at
the snake why would a dragon hoard gold
because a dragon represents everything
that you're afraid of what's embedded in
everything that you're afraid of
absolutely everything that you need to
find run from what you're afraid of run
from exactly what you need to find
one of the oldest dramatic
representations we know of not this
specific painting this is st. George and
the dragon
right dragon lives in the ground chase
there by heroes of previous generation
now and then reemerging kills people
right these are skulls around its lair
threatens the integrity of the community
like everything unexpected does hero
comes out slays the dragon frees the
treasure in this case it's a virginal
woman
dragon's hoard gold because the thing
you most need is always to be found
where you least want to look I'm going
to close this with another dream this is
a dream my five-year-old nephew had now
he got to get the context of this dream
right here after this dream parents were
divorced so there were dragons in the
house he was about four at this time is
running around the house with this
little plastic night helmet on and a
sort is zipping around killing things
with it doing this all the time and even
when he went to sleep at night he'd put
the the sword by his pillow and the
night helmet on his pillow now every
night or every second night or every
third night for six months he'd been
waking up screaming now why well he was
about to go to kindergarten right so
that's that's a real threshold for kid
way from maternal dependence
fundamentally into the real world that's
that's a new thing but also there was
upset in his house so I was there one
night when he woke up screaming next
morning I said well did you dream
anything and so he launched into this
story he said dwarf he was in this field
and these little creatures like dwarfs
we're coming up to him and they didn't
have any arms they just had legs and
they were it had big beaks and they were
covered with hair and grease and on top
of their head was a cross shaved into
this hair and there's lots and lots of
these Dwarfs and they were jumping on
him with their beaks biting him we all
looked to them thought well it's no
wonder you're waking up screaming right
I mean you know that doesn't sound so
good and then he said well wait there's
more right back in the distance there's
a dragon and the dragon is puffing out
fire and smoke and every time he pops
out fire and smoke it turns into these
dwarfs big problem right just like the
problem of the Hydra in Greek mythology
cut off one head seven more appear right
so what I'm going to do about these
dwarfs kill one big deal ten more coming
I said what can you do about that
now in a legal trial that would have
been an inadmissible question right
that's called leading the whip
because what I told him was despite the
horror of this situation you maybe could
do something about it honey said ha I
take my sword I get my dad that's a good
idea right dad there's the real dad and
then there's the tradition dad right you
might as well have your father by your
side if you're going to go into battle
I'd take my sword I get my dad I go to
where the dragon was I jump up on his
head I poked both of his eyes out with
this sword I'd go down his throat to the
place where the fire comes out I cut a
piece of that box out and I'd use it as
a shield
and I thought wow that's unbelievable
unbelievable that he could do that's
perfect right there's no sense going
after the dwarfs because thousands of
them you might as well go after the
dragon what happens if you go after the
dragon you get a piece of it right a
piece of its center nature a piece that
can defend you against anything
including other dragons so what if this
was the case thankful evolutionarily
speaking or religiously speaking what if
we were adapted to the world now what if
it's not the simple place of dead
objects that we think it is what if it's
something a lot more alive a lot more
like a story what if the story is
something like this you have absolutely
everything you need but you have to use
all of it if you run away from any of it
and in particular the parts of it that
frighten you which you know there's the
endless reasons to run away from if you
run away from any of it you don't get
that piece of the dragon if you miss
even one piece there's a in your
armor there's a place where you're
vulnerable if you make even one mistake
you lessen yourself if you lessen
yourself you're going to run away more
not only that when someone wants to lean
on you they're not going to be able to
lean on you because you'll just fall
over what if it was the case that we
were adapted to the world really adapted
to it so that if we made full use of all
the talents we had we'd be okay what if
it was the case that if we set out
consciously to never run away from
something we know we shouldn't run away
from that everything would be all right
you can think whatever you want to think
but this is what I think I think it's
bloody amazing that that little kids
book that I read you at the beginning of
this lecture had all that information in
it and so you might ask yourself when
you leave if that information isn't true
how the hell did it get there that's it
support Ontario's public television
donate at t v-- org